what about the other Chris he well
Emsworth is Godly he's a Godly Man you
when I have worked with him very few
times yeah it's hard not to his arm
being appropriate not like that to me is
handsome yeah but it is kind of wild yes
it's way bigger than my head yes I also
have a little head but it's way better
that's a huge jump but he also is
charming and fun and kind okay kind and
a good actor there are a few of them I
mean also you know Sebastian yes he's
kind of like watching hits with the ugly
sick no
um I don't really want to give Mackie
too much air time but he's quite a
beautiful specimen this week Mackie
feels great for himself he does that's
what I mean yes I do not need to inflate
that thing
inflated yeah it's wrong as well yeah